tenemos que este auto se aproxima a una
intersección a 60 millas por hora y en
este momento en este preciso momento se
encuentra a 0.8 millas de dicha
intersección ahora en ese momento
también un camión se aproxima a la misma
intersección por una calle que es
perpendicular a la calle donde viene el
auto y se encuentra ubicado a una
distancia de 0.6 millas de la
intersección aproximándose a la
intersección a una velocidad de 30
millas por hora y la pregunta es cuál es
la tasa a la cual la distancia entre el
auto y el camión está cambiando y para
responder a eso hay que tomar en cuenta
lo que nos están preguntando no están
preguntando la razón a la que cambia la
distancia del auto al camión en el
momento en que el auto se encuentra a
punto ocho millas de la intersección el
camión se encuentra a punto seis millas
de la intersección el camión va a 30
millas por hora y el auto viajando a 60
millas por hora cuál es la razón a la
que cambia esta distancia esta distancia
que tenemos aquí entre el auto y el
camión
esta distancia va cambiando designamos
la con una variable la variable es lo
que queremos encontrar entonces es en
este momento a que es igual de ese en dt
veamos entonces que conocemos para
encontrar o calcular cuál es el valor de
bs en dt bueno conocemos la distancia
del auto a la intersección llamémosle a
esa distancia la distancia que entonces
es igual a 0.8 millas vamos a ponerlo
por acá abajo y es igual a 0.8 millas me
jazz y también sabemos la velocidad es
decir de yen de t la razón a la que
cambia la distancia y con respecto al
tiempo es a sabemos que es igual a 60
millas pero considerando que el auto se
está acercando a la intersección éste es
igual a menos 60 millas por hora de
manera análoga
llamémosle a esta distancia x x va a ser
igual a 0.6 millas vamos a ponerlo aquí
x es igual a 0.6 millas y de x en dt la
velocidad del camión es 30 millas por
hora es un dato que nos dan pero
considerando que la distancia del camión
a la intersección está disminuyendo
entonces de x en dt es igual a menos 30
millas por hora
así pues conocemos lo que es lo que es x
lo que desde yen dt lo que desde x en dt
lo que necesitamos entonces es encontrar
una relación entre que x y s para que
derivamos esa expresión con respecto al
tiempo así es que aparentemente tenemos
todo lo que necesitamos para encontrar
de ese en dt cuál es entonces esa
relación entre x xi y s
bueno aquí tenemos un ángulo recto las
calles son perpendiculares así es que
podremos aplicar el teorema de pitágoras
cuadrada más cuadrada es igual a ese
cuadrado podemos entonces derivar con
respecto al tiempo ambos lados para
establecer relaciones entre los
elementos que ya obtuvimos aquí entonces
la derivada de x cuadrada con respecto a
te va a ser la viva de x cuadra con
respecto a x que es 2 x 2 x por la ayuda
de x con respecto a t que es de x en de
t
estamos aplicando en nueva cuenta la
regla de la cadena estamos derivando x
cuadrada con respecto a x y aquí x con
respecto a t lo mismo hacemos para y la
llevada de cuadrar con respecto al primo
derivamos yeguada con respecto a y que
va a ser 2 que multiplica de y en de t
la misma regla y la cadena y del lado
derecho hacemos lo mismo el mismo
argumento derivada de ese cuadra con
respecto a ese es 12 s por la derivada
de s con respecto a t se hace hincapié
que hemos aplicado en toda la expresión
la regla de la cadena y de esta
expresión conocemos x conocemos de x en
de te conocemos ya conocemos de jane de
t lo único que estamos calcular
ss para encontrar finalmente de ese en
dt la razón a la que esta distancia
cambia con respecto al tiempo entonces
cuánto vale s en este momento bueno
podemos usar el teorema de pitágoras
sabemos que lleva al punto 8x vale punto
seis vamos a calcularlo por acá abajo
esto va a ser igual a punto 6 al
cuadrado más punto 8 al cuadrado eso es
igual a ese cuadrada punto 6 al cuadrado
es punto 36.8 al cuadrado es igual a
punto 64 esto tiene que ser igual a ese
cuadrada esto nos va a dar uno igual s
cuadrada sólo queremos la distancia
positiva así es que ese es igual a 1
ya sabemos entonces lo que es ese
sustituyamos entonces todos estos
valores para encontrar lo que nos están
pidiendo de ese en dt que tenemos aquí 2
por equis y lo voy a hacer en amarillo 2
por x es 2 por 0.6 que es 1.2 por de x
en de teques menos 30 millas por hora
más
por punto 8 que es 1.6 por de yen de té
que es menos 60 millas por hora y no
estoy poniendo unidades aquí pero todas
las distancias son en millas todas las
razones de cambio las velocidades son en
millas por hora de tal manera que cuando
hagamos estas operaciones vamos a
obtener que descendente va a estar en
millas por hora te invito a que los
cheques te invito a que verifique es
esto de las unidades y esto va a ser
igual a 2 por s es igual a 1 va a ser
igual entonces a 2 de s en dt que lo que
queremos encontrar que tenemos entonces
del lado izquierdo del lado izquierdo
tenemos 1.2 x menos 30 esto es igual a
menos 36 la quinta parte de 36 esto es
menos 36 más 1.6 x menos 60 esto me da
menos 96 y esto es igual a 2 de ese ente
del lado izquierdo que tenemos menos 36
menos 96 es igual a menos 132 y esto va
a ser igual a 2
con respecto al tiempo dividiendo ambos
lados entre dos nos va a dar del lado
izquierdo menos 66 ya podemos poner las
unidades aquí millas por hora y esa es
la tasa a la cual la distancia está
variando con respecto al tiempo así que
descendente es igual a menos 66 millas
por hora y es correcto el signo negativo
que tenemos aquí por supuesto esta
distancia se está cortando a medida que
los vehículos se acercan a la
intersección